all right being is with us in Sioux City
Iowa hi Ben how are you great it's an
honor to talk to you Dave you too what's
up
so I'm calling because my grandmother
passed away recently and she left my
wife and I a $12,000 paid for car it has
10,000 miles on it but we have two cars
already one that's paid for and one that
has dead on it but we're just wondering
what to do with the car so the one
that's paid for is worth $3500 and the
one that has bet on it is worth about
10,000 but you know about eighty seven
hundred dollars on it and your
grandmother's car is worth what it's
worth about twelve thousand and how much
debt do you have other than your car
debt we have about twelve thousand debt
including the 8700 on top of the 8700
including so we have 8700 on a car so
you're so grounded calling your debt
free yeah the only thing is is that I
guess people in our family would rather
us not sell the car well then they can
bind well businesses that you're
supposed to keep a car as a as a
keepsake that's a big deep sigh maybe we
can sell it later just because she
passed away kind of recently that's the
only thing okay I'm confused she left
you the car and they have a say over
whether you sell the car you're probably
right I mean am i misunderstanding
something no you're not misunderstanding
anything okay and so whose mother was
this your mother's or your father's my
mother's mother yeah and your mother
doesn't want you to sell the car yeah
yeah yeah that figures so I don't know
you know I think your mom's grieving and
I understand that she lost her mom I
guess
that and so if you want to wait a little
bit that's fine but it's illogical for
you to have a $12,000 car sitting in
your driveway going down in value that
you don't need while you have 12,000
dollars in bed I mean does she want how
to keep the car and drive it I guess you
could sell your car yeah I mean I guess
it could do that yeah but it does make
the most sense to sell sell my
grandmother's car yeah I mean what is
your car what kind of car this 2006
Honda Civic the 8701 the $3500 one okay
one you owe 8700 is your wife's car then
okay
correct okay and what kind of car is
that at the Kia Optima okay what kind of
car is your grandmother have that would
be a Hyundai Sonata like a 2013 okay
doesn't sound like the same kind of car
to me I mean if you're if your wife
would rather drive your grandmother's
car keep it give it to your wife sell
the show your wife's car and same same
effect if you want to do that but other
than that I think you're going to have
to have a gentle kind clear conversation
with your mom and just come on this is
not it's not someone gonna be able to do
sorry love you but we can't do it